[Musique]
regardez
[Rires]
c'était il ya quatre ans on était en
sixième manche et regardez ici c'est à
dire ni là elle venait d'arriver de
mayotte
[Musique]
coucou c'est moi seillant mais là j'ai
changé c'est normal c'était il ya trois
ans mais attendez je vais prendre 5 du
crédit
tu es arrivé hier de mayotte aujourd'hui
c'est mon premier jour dans le nouveau
collège et sincèrement sans fournir
d'ici ce triste aujourd'hui on accueille
une nouvelle élève elle nous vient de
mayotte
elle s'appelle r'mila qui connaît bien
le collège avec toi yamila effet lui
visité le collège bon quand on ne le
savait pas ce moment-là mais les khaïmas
et sont du même quartier mais là j'avais
remarqué que j'étais stressé alors j'ai
voulu de suite de redonner jour mois
[Musique]
waouh c'est quoi ton projet moi tu vois
j'aime bien le volume et ça représente
quoi
ça c'est ce que je suis un terrien de
moi comme un noeud la matité quoi je me
plaigne de mai vibration intérieure et
ensuite je les traduis en couleurs après
cette première partie de la visite
tu t'es senti mieux ah oui j'avais
vraiment hâte de commencer ma première
heure de cours et si on leur parlait un
peu de ce qui se passe dans la cour
bonne idée bye bye bye
commençons par où ce sont les intellos
ils se réunissent tous les jours dans la
cour du collège
surtout ne parlez pas le régime les
livres
il est des veaux mais rapprochons-nous
[Musique]
venue du livre en ce moment et je suis
en train de terminer c'est bien quand
vous pouvez le voir il maîtrise tout et
technip tenir et liv et tourner les
pages
en plus ils ont un humour assez
particulier dont celui du suspense et
exaltant c'est profond c'est vraiment
envie de dévorer vraiment à ce point oui
moi ça m'intéresse
5 ou 2 mois la prochaine fois
ça c'est le coin des cagnards euh non
des canards il est vrai jamais travaillé
et pourtant les obsède des punks
c'est un peu louche je sais mais j'ai
jamais osé m'approcher pour découvrir
leurs secrets
vers 6 e et tous il faut pas faire
fléchir les gros rageux parce qu'il
n'entend pas faire comme ça macumba
donati votre travail ou ses fins mais
sinon
ok ok d'abord mais j'aurais assez
attention j'ai maintenant voilà beau
gosse et gennaro
[Musique]
avec et ses looks réseau sushi et
youtube collection les autres enfin mais
chassez le naturel il revient au galop
voici le gros dans 10ans causalité rozon
de paris en plus mal et de la
démographie ma fille ça va nous donner
du temps au milieu des mannequins au
pays
au collège il ya plusieurs juillet mais
il n'y a qu'un seul romeo et parfois
choisir c'est difficile
[Musique]
allez l on savait maintenant beaucoup
sur mes collèges il est temps de rentrer
dans mon quartier et de prendre mon
goûter et de retrouver ensuite mes amis
au case de l'oasis
mais sur le chemin de l'école
on a toujours des surprises par ailleurs
par ailleurs j'ai créé des têtes je suis
dans la famille quand tu te poses on me
dégoûter famous serein ça ils ont volé
ends sont en capitaine de grève ou ce
programme à perdre d'europe à la menace
un an que ses soldats
c'est cool maison et ça va la scb un
[Musique]
vase y monte monte
vous payez un coin donne les réponses du
brevet ce que veut on a tous les
réponses je te sens à l'âge de 100 ans
ouais super c'est une bonne journée
oil & gas revenez épouse
mais pour faire plus d'efforts c'est
quoi c'est quoi ces montres nous écoute
moi donne trois ans je peux avoir les
résultats du bac
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
aïda mbaye ailleurs la belle de mai à
leurs maris ailleurs au coeur de mon
quartier et j'attends mes camarades
juste devant lukas de l'oasis
ensemble nous allons faire un montage
vidéo
et oui car je tiens le voilà il ya là
bas
[Musique]
allez on vous laisse n'a jamais terminé
quand je pose on me dit que tu es famous
sur asahi l'on voit la n2 sont comme
capitaine rêve où ce programme apportera
pas la même ça fait un an qu'on s'écoute
besson et saviola est chaque fois avec
le soient toujours eu des rangs des
bancs jamais rombaut calais ici avec
commet pas de business - mines et non
dans la face à pézenas non répondent les
prochains pas non non je garde la fin
non